les querelles diplomatiques pourrait
bientôt se déplacer au dessus de nos
têtes l'espace est devenu un objet de
convoitise pour de nombreux pays
tout le monde veut sa part du gâteau et
forcément cela crée des tensions
le 23 juillet dernier les états unis ont
accusé la russie d'avoir testé une arme
qui pourrait être utilisé pour détruire
des satellites en orbite
les accusations démenties par moscou
dimitri peskov le porte parole du
kremlin a assuré que son pays restait
fidèle je cite à l'objectif de
démilitarisation complète de l'espace
appelant ainsi à la désescalade
nous appelons nos collègues américains
et britanniques à faire preuve de
professionnalisme et à s'asseoir à la
table des négociations plutôt que de
diffuser des messages de propagande
les deux pays ont rendez-vous à vienne
ce lundi
au menu des discussions la sécurité dans
l'espace car si de nombreux pays semble
afficher la volonté d'un usage pacifique
de l'espace pour reprendre l'expression
de la ministre française des armes et
florence parly elle a aussi admis que
c'était un lieu favorable aux manoeuvres
inamicale la france va donc se doter
d'outils qui lui permettront de répondre
à de potentielles attaques spéciales
il s'agit de prendre en compte le
passage d'une vision d'un espace bien
commun au service de la science un
espace dans lequel les puissances
continuent de se disputer la suprématie
mondiale nous disposerons d'un taux de
petits satellites patrouilleurs qui nous
permettront de détecter et caractériser
est attribué à leurs auteurs ce type de
manoeuvre inamicale car le coup d'envoi
de la course aux étoiles a bel et bien
été donnée ces derniers jours la chine a
lancé une sonde vers mars
objectif poser un module sur la planète
rouge puis déployer un robot téléguidé
qui aura pour mission d'y faire des
analyses
une mission qui met la chine en
concurrence directe avec les états unis
dans la conquête de mars
les etats-unis eux n'avaient annoncé la
création d'une force spatiale il y a
deux ans baptisé space force elle aura
pour but d'assurer la suprématie
américaine dans l'espace
l'espace a fondamentalement changé
depuis une génération
aujourd'hui d'autres nations cherchent à
perturber nos systèmes basés dans
l'espace et conteste comme jamais la
suprématie américaine pour la chine
donald trump eux veut transformer
l'espace je cite en champ de bataille
avec la création de cette force qui
selon pékin violent le consensus
international sur l'utilisation
pacifique de l'espace
des déclarations tous azimuts qui laisse
craindre une nouvelle escalade
diplomatique pour une place au milieu
des étoiles